♪ Will you take part in my life ♪
♪ My love ♪
♪ That is my dream ♪
♪ Life is so happy ♪
♪ It's what you make it ♪
♪ Always try to give ♪
♪ Don't ever take it ♪
♪ I just want ♪
- Hold on, getting a puppy is adorable,
but it's also a real challenge.
The last thing I want
you to do is get a puppy
and end up regretting it.
So, here are five things you must know
before you get a puppy.
(upbeat music)
Puppy depression is very common
and I'm not talking about
the puppy being depressed.
I'm talking about you.
- Not not me, you.
- You have all these expectations
that you and your puppy
are gonna be cuddling on the couch,
and the next thing you know,
the puppy just wants to
be alone in the kitchen.
This is very normal.
Don't have those feelings
of buyers remorse.
Give it time.
Allow the puppy to acelomate.
Training takes patience.
(upbeat music)
Feeding a young puppy is really tricky.
You have to feed them
up to four times a day,
especially ones as big as Bear.
Go get it.
A lot of people think they can
just free feed their puppies,
leave a bowl of food,
and the puppy will figure it out.
No, your puppy will become obese
and then guess what?
Every time your puppy eats,
it needs to poop.
So your house is going
to be covered in poop.
And have you ever seen a Newfie's poop?
- That is one big pile of (beep).
(upbeat music)
- Walking a puppy is no easy feat,
but it's extremely important.
Doesn't matter if it's raining,
if it's snowing,
you still have to walk your puppy.
And most people
get their puppies around 10 weeks of age,
which means that a walk is necessary
every three to four hours.
So, if you're working
an eight hour workday,
maybe a puppy isn't for you.
When walking your new puppy,
you may come off rude to other dog owners,
because you just can't let your puppy
play on leash with other pups.
It's gonna turn into trouble,
leashes are gonna get tangled,
someone's gonna get bitten.
Not a great idea.
Plus it's no good
if you want a well behaved puppy.
(dog growling)
(upbeat music)
Come on pup, good boy.
Dogs get dirty.
I mean, Bear when he sees mud,
he not only walks in it,
he lies down in it
he rolls around in it,
he drools in it, so.
But thankfully, he likes taking baths.
So it's not such a painful process.
But, some dogs hate baths.
So, it's really gonna be
personality dependent.
You really shouldn't
use human products on your dog.
No to human shampoo
and no to human hairdryers.
(air blowing)
Special dog dryer,
it's not too hot
and it essentially blows
the water off the dog.
(air blowing)
And it's not just bathing him,
you got to brush him,
you got to clip his toe nails.
This is a true time commitment.
(upbeat music)
Crate training is by far
the most effective way
to housebreak your dog,
and to make sure they
don't destroy your home.
- [Man] What the (beep) did you do?
- Go inside, good boy.
Dogs are den creatures,
they love enclosed spaces.
Bear goes in here after playing with Roxy
and it's his place to rest.
He sleeps here, he hangs out here
and he's not gonna pee in here,
because it's such an enclosed space.
Proving how much he loves his crate,
even when I open the door
he doesn't feel the need to run out.
Because, this is his home,
he loves it in there.
(cheering)
(upbeat music)
I did thorough research before I got Bear,
and I was warned about
drool in big breeds.
But, holy moly how much drool there is.
(upbeat music)
There's drool in my food,
I take drool with me
to work on my clothes,
it's on my mirrors.
The drool struggle is real.
(upbeat music)
The cost struggle is real too.
Outside of paying for basic pet supplies,
you also have to plan for
vet visits, vaccinations.
And if your pet gets sick,
the bills really rack up.
In fact, Bear's sick right now
and needs antibiotics.
This is expensive on any budget.
Look, I don't want it to seem
like I'm against you getting a puppy.
I love puppies.
I've made other videos
with these guys before
and they're truly part of my family.
But, I want you to be prepared
for the challenges that lay ahead.
So, if you know someone
that's about to get a puppy,
or thinking about getting a puppy,
definitely share this video with them.
If you enjoyed it, give it a like.
As always, stay happy and healthy.
Here, keep coming, keep coming.
Keep coming, come on more.
Roxy, you got to stay in one spot.
The cost struggle is real too.
Israel.
Against them.
(dog snorting)
I don't know what that was.
Oh.
Use a dog vacuum...
What is this thing called?
(happy music)